the more the media just let it out of
the closet exactly what they are the
more the blowback is coming and it's
going to come against the media too
there's a reason that right wing media
are growing and they will we will
continue to grow here at daily wire
because people don't want to get their
news from a bunch of partisan hacks who
won't announce that they are even
partisan
we here at the daily wire acknowledge
we're conservative i've told you i mean
i've told you go listen to positive
america go listen my show and then
where we agree on the fact pattern
that's the fact everything else is
opinion
and nobody on the left will do that
because they are liars because they lie
about their own agenda it's not just
they lie about the fact
they lie about their own agenda i don't
lie about my agenda you know my agenda
the moment you set foot
in the in hearing range of the show but
the media just lie to you and they lie
consistently and they lie with narrative
it's happening over and over and over
another example
so over the weekend there was a rather
major story
but it's not a major story because
here's the way it works when it comes to
crime stories
if there is a crime story that backs the
media narrative that america is
systemically racist and evil
and filled with white supremacist
right-wingers then that's a national
story
if a person who is not moving along with
that narrative commits a murder
in a high-profile fashion that's not a
national news story that's a local news
story
so if a white person kills a black
person on the street that's a national
story because it underscores the idea
that america is evil and systemically
racist and how could we be such a
terrible country if a black person kills
a white person on the street
which in terms of statistical
probability is actually more likely to
happen that's not a national story
that's a local news story
okay if you perfect example over the
weekend
it turns out that there was a an attack
on the us capitol police
uh a member of u.s capitol police was
killed by a person who drove a car
into the into two u.s capital police
officers
then got out of his vehicle with a knife
and then he was shot by the police
the immediate response by the media by
many of the media was this has to be
some
sort of white supremacist right this has
to be a q anon guy or something well
turns out not
it turns out that the the attacker
was a 25 year old black man who was a
follower of louis farrakhan's nation of
islam
this person's facebook page describes
himself as a follower of farrakhan
in which he said that farrakhan was
jesus
he said that he was his spiritual father
and he called himself noah x
many twitter accounts initially rushed
to assume the attack was carried out by
a white supporter of former president
trump
but the minute that it turned out that
this was a louis farrakhan supporter
boom it was gone from the media you
haven't heard about it at all
you haven't heard about it all just as
many police officers were killed
this week at the u.s capitol as were
killed on january 6th
and there was there was one police
officer we still don't know how he died
we don't know if he was murdered at the
capitol but
officer brian sicknick died maybe
presumably i mean again the facts are
still coming out
during the january 6th attacks and over
a u.s capital police officer was just
murdered over the weekend
it is not a national news story because
of the identity of the perpetrator the
media have decided
it's not a national news story because
they are partisan hacks
because all they care about is the
democrat leaning narrative and
let me just tell you this if that had
been a donald trump supporter every
republican
in america would have been asked about
how your vote for donald trump
effectuated this kind of thing but this
person was a follower of louis farrakhan
will a single democrat who's met with
louis farrakhan be asked about this
well a single democrat who's made nice
with lewis fairchild i'm talking about
representative hank johnson i'm talking
about rashida talib
i'm talking about ilhan omar i'm talking
about all the democratic members
who have been warm with figures from
nation of islam will any of those people
be asked at all about their association
with with
a person of that ideology no
don't be silly don't be silly because
that of course is a local news story
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content